العالم يقف مشدودا قلقا يراقب التصعيد غير
المسبوق في البحر الاسود نظرا لاهميته
الجيوستراتيجيه بوصفه طريقا رئيسيا
للتجاره الخارجيه للدول المتشاطئه باتجاه
البحر المتوسط ويعد مسارا مهما لتصدير
الطاقه لاسيما لروسيا وطموحاتها بالوصول
الى دول جنوب اوروبا والمياه الدافئه
روسيا تستند في السيطره على البحر الاسود
بتاريخها منذ اواخر القرن الثامن عشر
اتخذت الخطوه الاهم بسيطرتها على شبه
جزيره القرم واعاد الضمها باراضيها لتحافظ
على المقر التاريخي لاسطولها هناك
وفي حربها على اوكرانيا عززت من ترسانتها
لتوسيع هيمنتها وسيطرتها وعماد الترسانه
اسطول حديث متعدد القدرات القتاليه
التقليديه وغير التقليديه ولا تمضي اسابيع
دون ان تعلن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
ادخال قطع او اسلحه جديده لهذا الاسطول كل
هذه القدرات تضعها روسيا داعما لاي تحرك
لها دون ان تخفي دور الاسلحه الميدانيه
ومنصاتها البحريه استثمار ضخم على المديين
القريب والمتوسط لدعم تحركات الجيش الروسي
البريه فمسك تدرك ان بقائها في شبه جزيره
القرم سيضمن سطوتها على البحر الاسود
ويبقيها على مقربه من المتوسط وبحار اخرى
والبحر الاسود ايضا منطلق روسي لضرب العمق
الاوكراني دون استنزاف ترسانتها الاكثر
حداثه لاسيما ما تسميها موسكو اهدافا
استراتيجيه كمراكز التحكم والقياده
الاوكرانيه البعيده مئات الكيلومترات اما
اوكرانيا التي خسرت تدريجيا مواقعها على
البحر الاسود فتعمل في البحر كما البر
الصليب تكتيكيه غير تقليديه اسلحه توقع
خسائر بليغه لكن دون مواجهه مباشره ومع
ارتفاع نوعيه الدعم العسكري الغربي لكييف
بدات الهجمات الاوكرانيه تاخذ منحا اكثر
نوعيه بما يشكل ضغطا وتهديدا على القوات
الروسيه في شبه جزيره القرم وطرق امداد
الجيش الروسي الى المناطق التي اقتطعت من
اوكرانيا سواء عام 2014 او منذ شنه روسيا
الحرب عام
وبهذا يتحول البحر الاسود ايضا مجالا
حيويا عسكريا تتحرك فيه اوكرانيا دون ان
تضطر لان يكون لها قطاع بحريه تقليديه
[موسيقى]